killed in a bomb blast at a shia mosque
in peshawar in northern pakistan
authorities have declared a state of
emergency let's go straight to kamalhada
who's on the line
from haripur kamal what do we know
well according to the report the
attacker
engaged two guards at an entrance to a
shia mosque in the city of peshawar
in the old part of the city um one guard
was killed instantly the other
sustained critical injuries
and is said to be in serious condition
but then the suicide bomber got inside
that mod there was a friday prayer being
held by
worshippers there and then detonated his
device inside the building
causing a high number of casualties
according to the reports coming out of
the hospitals and the police sources
some of the wounded are said to be in
serious condition now it must be
remembered that there have been a number
of attacks carried out in pakistan this
one particularly carries the hallmarks
of dice
which is on the run in afghanistan and
has been able to carry out attacks
inside pakistan so at the moment the
death toll mounting uh and of course an
emergency being declared in the
hospitals
in the province uh of cyber broken
empire in the provincial capital all
right kamal i'm sure we'll be checking
back in with you as more information
comes to hand for now thank you for that
come on